eyes are moving all my [ __ ] days I
can't make any money I'm [ __ ] sick of
these [ __ ] people I'd help you
darling you okay
okay I can make money smug advising he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] let me give you
something just to help you out today
right
hmm let me give you some money just to
help you out a little bit right you want
you want to come by my place just to
hang out sure here hop in
they still keep looking still keep
blocking me man unblock thing come on
tell me you want one must learn what is
this big [ __ ] damn it down get him
get [ __ ] die [ __ ] come what are you
staying up
what you smoked last night oh nothing
about that no no no it's [ __ ] them
trying to take the riches of God did I
just brought two dollars and get out
I've just - it - I've said sir I tried
to give it back to you if I made money I
always pay people back these people
won't even let me [ __ ] make any money
to pay anybody back mr. money can see if
it comes to me later I'll take care of
you for eight years eight years ago
is it time went by pretty fast yeah
about eight or nine years oh I guess I
just been taken apart really my body
yeah I smoke black crack I do crack well
see what yeah I always smoke back in
yeah but uh you know the heroin is too
tannin and the heroin the tannin was in
the environment and these people saw
this whole these group of people that
they left I guess rise above with God
and and they knew it was from tanana
Dion that they got really powerful and
strong
they took tannin out of the out of the
environment so these people couldn't
prevail and they made it into Elmen and
that's what heroin is is tannin it's a
it's a holder of tannin and just a whole
crack is a coconut but everybody needs
it it's more than it's more than what
you think the coconut and it also makes
people a little bit clairvoyant a little
bit they could see cameras they could
see some pendant yeah there I don't
differ about some I go to my friend's
place in the city of Vernon um I go to
Mario's out Mario's it's like a junkyard
I sleep in a u-haul truck with him it
looks like it's decorated it's painted
inside and there's varnish and enamel
flowers painted but it's really I do see
on the street i go to i go there i go to
but yeah i'm my friends have a 10 on san
julian they've been letting me sleep in
it by myself which has been really nice
but there's all kinds of trajectory like
if you could see like the amount of
trajectory being pulled on my teeth my
upper molars it's it's i'll be i won't
have any teeth in the matter of very
fast if it somebody doesn't do something
about it
really fast well I don't know but I know
there's a woman to the right of me you
know if I'm sitting in my tent
woman to the right me and then there's
some people on the left me the sky
Dennis I think she's the possessor of
him or or or some greater force but um
but they're doing something with it
because I know she's the trajectory
that's her employment with this regime
on the streets here is dealing with the
trajectory and the returns how the
trajectory intertwines with the returns
when they like today we we saw some of
it no like it for instance whatever was
taken removed for Mark's body that's bad
if it returned it got returned because
of this [ __ ] trajectory being put in
my teeth and and other people me maybe
even himself you know so everything that
um and this linguistics thing they've
been they stole certain sounds from my
mouth and so when I've been saying let
me see this these templates and things
they made with this these linguistic
stop that were stolen it all of a sudden
it lightens them up and it shows it it
does show when you when you lie in a
sheet steel
it does show up you know it did it comes
out and it started to come out I'm a
prostitute
yeah prostitute again I hate it so I'm
out there usually I I service about
sometimes five six o'clock in the
morning if not the latest I'll get back
there about eight o'clock unless I sleep
all day which I'll get there like two or
three so you got it yeah I I just keep
doing it when as I go along I buy my
stuff and I take a break then I go back
I just chase it all day I haven't gotten
to that point where I'm trying to fix ax
I'm I'm trying to do so many other
things and I feel like I'm here my mom
just moved to Seattle to she just moved
in with my sister so I can't really go
back home now and so you know I'm gonna
try to get some housing so I want my
daughter to come stay with me
you know I saw her last week you know I
went down to Orange County to see my mom
I just happened to call there I was in
my friend's car and they were just
filling up the moving truck they were
leaving the next day my sister was here
from Seattle I got to see her after like
15 year or you know 10 15 years yeah
that was really nice I had a great I had
a good time although I was in the car a
couple times getting high but I just I
couldn't handle the whole pressure just
being down there and the still moving
thing and
not knowing where my daughter was gonna
be 21
yes she's 21 and she she she might go to
school but I don't know she went she
drove she drove there with him she
wasn't gonna drive there I called it
like the next week and she was with him
where she was with her dad that lives in
Vancouver Washington which is not far
from Seattle I guess so she was she
drove out there with him so she'll come
back on the airplane and I don't know
where she's going she's okay with me yes
totally yeah she I think she loves me no
matter what
what kind of things do you say to her I
hug her a lot
well because I hear screaming all the
time when I'm on the street here because
she's the savior the big savior there's
something big about her that these
people are got everybody like like
almost like evil robots they say it's
from my breasts like if I could pull
them back right now they have any of
them out you know and these little
people all over my body that are in
there just sending all my colored energy
out and they're doing a lot of bad stuff
I met this guy yesterday that I did a
date with him I saw him on merchant he'd
been in my body since for 48 years he's
lived in my body
yeah and he's only been out of my body
two times yesterday was one of them I
met him and he he said they ran he can't
believe what the scams they pulled on
him I just showed him maybe three things
off my my god sense and he was like
tripping so that even being in inside
the body of this of me you can get
fooled really bad because there's some
scandalous people that really need to
get out of there and so that's who I'm
trying to say him if somebody can see
this on YouTube you need to go and you
need to to see who's connected to my
nose and how much power they have in my
nose to swallow the breasts and all the
switching exchanging trading and if you
don't understand it just start with that
you'll get
but as well as my feet had been taken my
I think the sky took the top part of my
vagina like the the mound and one day I
got out of this guy's suburban near
McDonald's I couldn't do anything but
just a masturbate on on Olympic and
Central Avenue on the corner I was
laying there masturbating in front of
the cars because if something went wrong
with my body somebody took something
really really super important and my
body just went into just and then I know
why it didn't fix it still didn't fix I
can feel it this injury like this thing
but I'm I know because and look at these
people if you could see the people
walking by I mean it wasn't a lot of
people but those people were holding a
lot of blocks on this injury just like
they were on the women this guy hit my
nose really hard like I would be on life
support
they held the injury and it's all
working on magic on my deep body magic
so you know anything running on that
that part that's that isn't keeping me
alive and some other people alive
yeah it could keep everybody alive so
yeah and it uh and anybody that's hooked
on that to do bad stuff you that's just
a guarantee you know they need to get
off you know and I hope they that
they're starting with that and then
working with my charisma which they've
made into magic and then when I say
magic they all get these pieces of magic
and um you know it sounds like I'm crazy
but this is really true it's all these
pieces of me and then there are so many
pieces of me and they've been taking
copies of my daughter and pieces of her
to where they said she's not even there
was nothing left and they put her in the
ocean
me her her spirit her person her me and
your was yourself right so when they
said that I didn't really believe him
but I've been thinking about it a few
times every time I try to rescue my
mother who's a prisoner too it's just
like this long and winding road
it's very skinny and private almost down
on down below and it shut it in my date
yesterday open it back up and that is
his a trooper I had the whole thing shut
the Finney's I guess it's the finished
car and I'm not against him but I know
they're deep possession but I know it
sounds so crazy but but I want it on
tape yeah and on what one other things I
hear my mom screaming to and my dad
screaming - I hear my dad screaming yeah
yeah he's he's passed away but he that
he yeah he
yeah you wants to get all the debris to
police the US Marines police but my cell
yeah my sister lives in Seattle and her
daughter Elizabeth and drew and her
husband Mark and his family the
counselors as well as the Keith's they
all have omnipresence it's on us just
like they have an omnipresence for you
and are you involved in yours property
or not so you're not it is you're just
mark okay well these people have so
they're using pure and holy people like
mark myself and you should see what they
have these people doing that are part of
pieces of us and I keep seeing to undo
them in it I just haven't gotten all the
way I know there's maybe that's why I
sit and try to eat like I'm eating a
chicken broth with stuffing today three
different kinds of cereal just trying to
do whatever I can and in green bean
juice you know and I know they took all
this out of it so
I hope you get to - are you bored yeah
yeah thank you
I really appreciate mark he's really
cool I hope many contributions could be
given to a lady he deserves it okay well
I'm really happy yeah that was boring
okay woman I hope I'm a good inspiration
to this so so you even murdered three
times huh
how did they murdered a few times
strangulation muscle stomach where I
went it is shocking passed out
oh no I have murdered many more times
every time I go to sleep I burn with the
miracle they use a miracle to put me
down
you wake up every morning I always wake
up now anyway I wake because I don't die
or I did